what does it mean to live free and die
well
sure so it's wrapped up in our whole
Warrior poet ethos that's living for
higher purpose being ready to sacrifice
in the defense of others ultimately to
live well in the present you have to
really start with the end in mind uh
lots of folks just go through life in an
extremely reactionary manner things
happen the Tyrant of the Urgent comes up
and before you know it all of your
waking hours and even you're kind of off
hours are spent stressing about stuff
though if you were given a death
diagnosis you know you are terminally
ill much of the stuff that we droll on
with every single day would immediately
sift to the edges of our attention as
not important and what can happen in the
tyranny of the Urgent is the most
important stuff gets shuffled to the
back
being able to die well means that you
live the life that was worthy of your
calling so to speak and in so doing uh
you're able to live well with uh kind of
that end in mind and so in my estimation
having faced death you know many
different times it really allowed me to
focus on what did I what I wanted to do
in life and so it turns out that you'll
die the exact same way that you live
whether that's poorly or well
I love the tyranny of the urgent I
absolutely love that I think it's it's
so accurate for how many people live
their lives there was this meme that I
saw floating around a while ago that
said um
adulthood is just one series of weeks
after the next saying after this week
it'll calm down and then you die oh it's
such a trap you know folks think of like
me and my my nine to five sucks and uh
if I can just get through all the chores
and the tasks and I fix up the house and
I pay that off and I work and you know
ultimately one day I'll have a nest egg
big enough and then when I'm 65 years
old I'm gonna really start living that's
when it'll get really good and what you
don't realize is that is overrated once
you even get there uh you look back of
like no no let's start living well right
now all there is is today you're not
promised tomorrow and so I don't want to
delay living and having a meaningful
impact on the world around me for hoping
that one day I can start living right
you mentioned that you've faced death uh
you were in the armed forces for a long
while you did a number of Tours and you
were in some kinetic uh encounters I
guess you could say
what was the closest that you think you
came to death
I wasn't in I wasn't in a long while I
did a I packed a whole bunch of combat
into a shorter period time so I did five
combat tours but I jumped around and did
a whole bunch of stuff in my life
closest I've gotten to death who knows I
was in a near Ambush you're not supposed
to live through those those are really
really awful I got a far Ambush as well
what's the difference between a near and
a fire Ambush uh well proximity but a
near Ambush is supposed to be 35 meters
and in it's basically hand grenade range
and so the idea is your movement you're
moving whether it's on foot or through
vehicle we happen to be
um uh stripped down Humvee so we didn't
have doors we didn't have ceilings or
anything no armor so we were able to
Rangers jump out and in a moment be
ready to fight so we didn't like all the
armor stuff it just ends up being just a
a metal coffin to us but we got hit I
was the lead driver it's kind of like a
fire breathing team leader you want
somebody who is going to react well
under pressure and so that was kind of a
nice position because I'm Target number
one in something like a near Ambush if
you take out the lead driver all the
vehicles stop then you kill the the rear
driver and then it's just a massacre
kill box and so your job in an ambush is
to punch out and that's what we did
we're able to punch out at like a 50 cal
ammo from up top came out of its uh K uh
came out of its ammo box it's like hit
me in the head and I'm supposed to drive
but some RPG or IED blew out my front
right tire and so it takes two arms to
rip my steering wheel over and I'm going
down this road which is really just this
horrible dried up creek bed that just I
mean you have to really plan your route
to figure out how you're not going to
high Center somewhere and so it's just a
mess and this 50 cal Amos hit me in the
helmet and I'm I'm wanting to get in the
fight and shoot at the same time but I'm
supposed to punch out and so man it was
a mess it could have been that or it
could have been uh you know that that
sucked
um you never know how many things where
you were kind of in enemy crosshairs and
nothing went wrong whether they could
have shot you but you didn't so you
don't really counting any of that stuff
uh gun fights uh rating terrorist
training camps or uh or
um one of my very first uh and closest
interactions that I ever got into it's
like room on room gunfight and uh that
was real close and after you know coming
through a doorway and uh putting this
Joker down uh we looked and right over
my upper left shoulder were SKS uh
bullet holes in the wall that that one
that one's kind of that improved my
prayer life so
[__] yeah I'm I've always been
fascinated by this
in scenarios like that
what is the balance of
fear or being scared
compared with a more tense encounter
where it's more protracted maybe it's at
night maybe you're creeping up on an
enemy location maybe you're moving from
room to room
I I'm always interested in this because
I think when people think about that
being scary
I'm not sure if that's an accurate
representation of the flood of hormones
that your body's going to dump into you
I would imagine that that's just kind of
hectic and an intense but there will be
more scary situations you get into that
are less kinetic immediately
great question I wish I could take fear
and put it in this polished nice box
where it's kind of like here it is but
truth be told it's a lot of uh lunging
forward and doing well and then all of a
sudden being set back and you're kind of
like I thought it was over this because
even looking back I remember a couple
different freezing points where the the
terror was so Stark I just locked up I
couldn't move and it could have happened
that something had gone bad in that
moment and I would have had to carry
that my whole life thankfully you know
those moments uh though I remember two
different freezing points where it was
just so horror horrifying I couldn't
really handle it I think you know in my
head it was like I was my legs were
concrete for minutes at a time it was
probably just a few seconds and I was
able to kind of get out of that and
press forward other times I've been able
to just I should have been scared but I
really wasn't sometimes I got just
pissed like you try to kill me how yeah
and you just go to work how dare you try
to kill me I'm gonna kill you back and
so sometimes it's rage other times and
this is the best one is it's not
horrible fear and it's not rage it's
just calm cold mass and that that's
where I really wanted to live and work
and that was really the goal is though
the world is on fire and falling apart
around you and you're pretty sure you're
about to eat it you're just gonna do the
right thing and make the next right
decision and calm Cool Waters on the
surface and raging uh heart underneath
and so I want cold hard math and that's
really I think the most ideal goal would
you mind telling us those stories that
you said when you froze
one is well let's see one is kind of
stupid because it was a nothing mission
for me and that there was hot stuff
happen around like I had my buddy had
his leg blown off and we were raiding a
terrorist training camp and I was just
coming to kind of the edge of this
Ravine there was Tall Grass uh we had
just come in on some birds and uh rotary
Wing that it just dropped just like half
a click out I mean hustled over and my
night visions fogging up and whatnot and
we're looking out and you know I'm doing
pretty well but then somebody says hey
they're uh they're climbing up the
cliffs maybe someone said it maybe I
imagined it but I realized as if just
the way the terrain was if they kind of
climbed up and popped up we'd be face to
face you know just and I wouldn't be
able to see them coming it was just too
much noise and fire and smoke and guns
and uh you just couldn't hear a lot you
know I realized man I'm really blind
here and if I am to sneak out a little
bit farther so I have visibility down
I'm gonna be perfect perfectly backlit
because of the illumination and so I
knew better tactics than to make that
mistake very good Target yeah you'll be
you'll be Skyline you'll be silhouetted
and so you've got to be able to read
lighting conditions even under nods
night vision and so I knew enough to be
like Manny if if you uh Skyline yourself
right there in the Ravine anybody in
there is going to see me and light me up
like a Christmas tree and so I was just
kind of stuck in an awkward place I'm
like I hated my terrain I hated my
position and we already got dudes
screaming and we got a Medevac going
over but it wasn't
I should have been able to do better
than that for so whatever reason it just
freaked me out I just I couldn't handle
it in the moment you know and I'd
handled other stuff that was scarier
before that and after that and so here
here's a lesson I learned is no one ever
Masters fear
every single day you got to get up and
their fear will manifest itself in a
million different ways uh there it was
kind of gun fighting and it's more sexy
and glamorous to some of the viewers but
I mean like hey man getting out and
getting in small business that's scary
confronting your you know friend about
something or having an uncomfortable
conversation or risking being canceled
or losing your job there's all kinds of
ways that fear can come up and get you
but I've I've performed everywhere on
the scale of absolute hero and absolute
zero
um and just because you have performed
bravely in the past is no guarantee you
will per um you will behave bravely in
the future every day you got to keep
earning it which sucks because I'd like
to be like yep I have arrived I'm
amazing and it's just not true it sucks
yeah I think a lot of people who see
guys like yourself with you know a
heroic past serving the country would
presume that well he's been in
firefights he's been shot at there's
been bullets
a couple of inches above his shoulder
and across from his head therefore
the normal vicissitudes of Life they're
just gonna it's gonna be water off a
duck's back how much have you found
The Bravery or your ability to overcome
challenges and fear and freezing in
those scenarios cross over to fears of
being canceled you've got a huge huge
YouTube channel that you're in risk of
losing that if you say the wrong thing
you've got the stresses of coordinating
a team you've got concerns am I saying
it right am I saying it right is this
serving the audience in the right way
just how different is that
it's different and it's not
fear management and being able to
inoculate yourself against all the fear
stuff that's all usable stuff but a lot
of vets get out and they don't make the
jump case in point I have a buddy at 19
or 20 combat tours I had five and that's
a lot I did a lot he did 19 special
forces it's like this guy's a hero a lot
of guys are they know one thing very
well and uh you know it's a terrifying
and scary thing the most but it's
familiar you know that this is what we
do we go out and Hunt bad guys and they
hunt us back and we see how it goes uh
but they're very terrified to get out in
the civilian World they don't know how
to do just basic some basic life so
there was this one guy
um a special forces guy I'm talking
about he would he got out in the
civilian World he's finally done and uh
he was wrestling with this contract and
he couldn't do it and he listened like
John I I can run toward gunfire but
contracts freak me out that's a quote
and so I mean fear just because you've
done well in one sector doesn't
necessarily mean that you're going to be
able to effectively and seamlessly pull
that over into all other areas you know
you have some grisly
soldiers not afraid of al-Qaeda
terrified to speak to girls and girls
are scary in their defense you know how
that's gonna go girls are scary so I'm
not cast in shade I've been married 16
years I love my wife I lead my wife I'm
in charge but she is uh she can be scary
so
yeah okay I think that's really
important to remember that you have to
earn it every single day you know there
are new challenges that are going to
face you and you can't rest on your
laurels you know
I've noticed periods in my life where
I've
started to take my foot off the gas and
I'm starting it's not even put on the
gas necessarily it's being less
intentional I think that's the the main
predeterminant that's the lead measure
of what happens and the lagging measure
is my sleep's off or I don't feel so
good or I'm not eating well or my
relationships are suffering or I'm not
showing up on the show as well as I
should do
the lead measure is not being
intentional and and a lot of the time
that is born out of fear okay well what
if this goes wrong what what if I look
stupid what if I what if I whatever
there was this um we recently hit a
million Subs on the channel and I did
this video
um sort of reacting to it live and it
was a little bit emotional but then I
felt silly about it being emotional and
I thought oh well well you know it's
just a number on a screen this is lame
getting emotional about you know hitting
this subscriber Milestone even though
it's been you know tens of thousands of
hours over half a decade and started in
my living room and now it's this you
know this big thing and we get to travel
all over the world and it's a dream life
and I brought one of my best friends
along with me and all this stuff but it
still felt silly
and I was like okay well that that's
another opportunity to try and lean into
fear it's not the same sort of fear of
being shot at in a Humvee but it's it
was [__] terrifying you know to think
oh I'm gonna put this video out and what
if people are going to laugh at me what
if people think that it's stupid
um so yeah every single day there are
different challenges and I I think
you're right you can't just
um rely on the momentum or the inertia
of having previously been brave and
presuming that that's going to carry you
through things in future yeah well hey
congratulations you turn a million that
is a big accomplishment I think that is
absolutely awesome and I I didn't know
much about your channel now I'm a
follower I am tuning in I like your
style bro you're all right and so yeah
I'll be tuning in bro got the seal of
approval okay so uh why do you think the
world is in need of Warriors at the
moment not everybody needs to be in
active duty we don't have anywhere near
as many kinetic altercations across the
planet you know unless you're Russian or
Ukrainian America seems to be pretty
peaceful at the moment why why do we
even need Warriors
right and so I know the military
recruiting is 25 down off its Mark and
so the military would say we need
Warriors but I when I use the word
Warrior I don't mean everybody needs to
wear multi-cam and get nods sidebar
multi-cam is really fun yay for guns get
lots of that stuff and all right but
really I think Warrior is has to do with
more of the heart of a man and who he is
I think men are made to be strong and
we're supposed to be protectors and
providers and those warrior-like
attributes are absolutely critical to be
successful as a man it's part of your
calling I'm supposed to be able to be a
leader and bold and fearless and
courageous I'm supposed to have grit so
that I can carry heavy burdens that's
all the good warrior stuff and so even
if you're not getting shot at by Charlie
hiding in the bushes all the virtues uh
and the strengths of a warrior are
absolutely critical for men to succeed
in
what does a poet have
that a warrior does not in that case all
the important stuff so I like to liken
it well so you know there's the first
and second amendment and we'll use that
as a metaphor for what I'm about to say
the Second Amendment is the right to
bear arms and it's absolutely critical
because it is the big bodyguard of all
the other amendments if you don't have
the right to bear arms ultimately you're
going to lose your first amendment which
is packed full with all the good stuff
that's uh you know freedom of press and
religion and freedom of speech and due
process all that stuff and so Second
Amendment is the only thing that will
ultimately keep tyrants at Bay now it
may be way far in the future or maybe
whatever but ultimately all laws are
protected and sustained by force and so
if all force is abdicated to a
government even if the government is
super swell and Sweetie Pies one day
tyrants will take over that it's just
the natural progression of all Nations
over time and when that happened and the
people will have no recourse and that's
why our Founders put a second amendment
in I am doing my second amendment
activism thing I'm getting on a rabbit
Trail I'm pulling back into frame here
and second amendment safeguards the
First Amendment but the First Amendment
isn't a means to an end like the Second
Amendment is it's a means in and of
itself so there's the protection of
freedom and there's the enjoyment of
freedom and it is the free man's duty to
both protect and enjoy and so all the
stuff that matters most in life is
packed in to the uh poet
archetype and so that's uh loving my
wife and raising my kids it's searching
out truth in finding truth Having the
courage to actually face facts and then
be able to bring that in my heart and
tell the truth boldly in daring and
interesting beautiful ways now in this
is philosophy and it's religion and it's
all the stuff that that uh brings in of
meaning and hope and morality all that
stuff that's in the poet area and so
Warrior and poet must be embodied in the
same man or men are supposed to be both
we're supposed to be lovers and Fighters
not one of the other in every single one
of our Brides or girlfriends wishes
perhaps they don't have the words that
we're using here but they want you to be
bold and dare they want a leader they
want your strength but they also want
your heart they want to be able to be
emotionally able to connect with you
they want to be swept off their feet
with strong arms that is romantic you
know and so they want the romance too
they want the whole thing and so it's
not lover or fighter it's both it's lion
and lamb Warrior and poet
what are we missing more of at the
moment because it seems to me you know
the hard times soft men meme that kind
of is being shared a lot at the moment I
I'm not convinced that soft men are
necessarily loving men I I would go as
far as to say that
there's some pretty big lacks on the
loving and the Heart side from guys as
well I think that a lot of men are
floundering with regards to their
position what is it that I'm supposed to
do I I I'm scared of being seen as a
tyrant if I try to enact anything that's
too overbearing or masculine but without
that if I try to do the polarity which
is the the loving soft sort of cuddly
side that makes me feel weak because I
don't have anything to contrast that
against so right what's your what's your
uh conception of the Topography of
current modern masculinity and manhood I
think passive men are neither Warriors
nor poets they're they're weak in both
areas uh and so yeah it's not that oh
we're too poet-esque if like no you're
not in poet poet enough uh passive men
are not active in pursuing their brides
and dating them for Life they're not
romantic they're not vulnerable they're
not seeking out capital T truth they're
sitting on a beanbag chair playing video
games a eight hours a day they're just
login time at work they would do
anything to self-preserve and stab
someone in the back if they need to
they'll be nice guys you know maybe
they're polite maybe they're real funny
uh but they're not making a mark in any
area of warrior or poet so
um I think men today need to grow in
both aspects however I do think men are
predisposed to be one more of the other
I'm naturally more uh lion I'm naturally
more war Warrior I had to learn through
a painstaking process how to save my
marriage which was really rough for the
couple years and first couple years and
now it's it's really awesome I'm 16
years in bro and I can I wish I wish I
could I wish I could just take what's in
my head and heart and put it forth and
say guys you have no idea how amazing a
flourishing wife is and the power and
passion and depth of that safe monogamy
and it is incredible incredible uh but
you got to fight your way into that and
so I wouldn't change that for anything
in the world
um my faith as well of like it grows
over time and so that right there has
become the most important aspect of my
life but uh passive men don't pursue
those Endeavors and I had to really I
mean it's like the heart stuff I feel
like just a dumb idiot uh where I'm
pretty good at taking a punch uh I'm
pretty good at pushing through pain and
limits and sucking it up I can do all
that stuff when I need to Foster
boldness and aggression I know how to
flip those switches as well but being
able to turn down the dial in be loving
and affectionate and emotionally
vulnerable and really know what in the
world is going on with my heart in the
first place you know it's like I'm the
dumb I'm the last one to know my wife
knows when I'm off way before I know
when I'm off and so and then even when
I'm off like you had mentioned before of
like uh how do you get in that kind of
fog and hey maybe I'm not performing
well on camera and something's off with
me and I don't know exactly what it is
and perhaps it's fear or apathy apathy
when I start getting apathetic about
stuff I realize ah there may be fear
under there there may be some type of
tension I need to lean in and see what
in the world's going on with me
for the guys that are listening who
think
that sounds a lot like me the guy that
is able to embody
more masculine virtues maybe they're not
a a fighter maybe they're not out there
taking punches and kicking indoors but
can lean into that more stoic resilient
nose against the grindstone type of
person tactically
what did it look like or what were the
most powerful practices or things that
you did that allowed you to open up
without feeling
weak or fragile
yeah and so I think there is a terrible
misunderstanding about what strength
really is of like when I think a strong
man I don't think you got lats growing
out of your ears down to your shoulder
of like in your your deadlift is 700
pounds but if you do have a 700 pound
deadlift bro I'm gonna buy you a beer
that's amazing Bravo uh man there's all
kinds of different areas where a man
needs to be strong one is physical it's
the least important unless you're
fighting Vikings or something like that
uh there's emotional strength you know
like if somebody cuts you off in traffic
and you lose your mind over that you're
a pathetically weak dude you're angered
too easily really that sets you off you
can't even control your own stupid
temper your weak man man you're weak and
you need to grow in your emotional
stability and faculties right I think uh
your spiritual strength is more
important than any of it and and from
that uh your character your morality
your your uh all your meaning and
purpose is really going to flow from
that I think mental strength pick up a
book brother you got to be smart you
can't just work really hard grind it out
and expect your life to go really well
of that life is a series of all kinds of
different puzzles and you gotta be smart
to be able to figure this out like for
instance you don't talk to chicks the
same way you talk to dudes and if you
try to you're going to destroy your life
you'll feel tough but you're an idiot
you're going to destroy all your
relationships because you're an idiot
and so we need to get stronger in all
those different areas
I wrote a newsletter a couple of weeks
ago that I think is very similar to this
I'm going to read it to you now so I did
a podcast episode with uh Chris Bumstead
he is the Mr Elite Olympia classic
physique Champion four years in a row
this guy is he looks like he's carved
out of stone uh he's the modern day
Arnold Schwarzenegger people are making
a lot of comparisons and during it we
spoke a lot about vulnerability
so quote never be vulnerable in front of
your girlfriend is common manosphere
advice the guy that I was talking to is
more Alpha than pretty much every other
human that's ever existed and yet he
told me a story of how he sobbed on the
bathroom floor in his girlfriend's arms
when the pressure got too much for him
then he got up dusted himself off and
went to dominate his challenges and
become a world champion here's the thing
hiding your vulnerability from the world
doesn't make you any less vulnerable it
just makes you less honest you don't
change the way you feel by hiding your
feelings from the world limits on speech
are just limits on sincerity if you
believe that being vulnerable makes you
a [__] how do you arrive at the
conclusion that feeling vulnerable and
also not being able to open up about it
somehow makes you less of a [__]
I love that I would probably uh I agree
with it I love it uh however I'd
probably replace vulnerability with
something like humility humility would
be something that would be better
outward facing to the public of
everybody watching the screen I let me
model humility but I don't know you I'm
not necessarily going to be vulnerable
with you I may have enemies out there
I'm not going to show you my soft
underside of that's that would be a
mistake uh You Know You're vulnerable
with uh wolves in sheep's clothing at uh
work and one day they're going to crush
you for that and it'll be your own
stupid Folly you shouldn't have done
that you shouldn't have been vulnerable
with those people but you should be
humble with those uh people now the
people you love love risks love allows
uh somebody to be able to wound you you
can't love and also Safeguard and
protect yourself at the same time it
opens up uh wide arms and and bears its
soul to someone and so uh in the aspects
of that I think you should be vulnerable
to those who have your trust but that's
kind of a sacred thing now I'll be
vulnerable in some other more
superficial ways and I don't mind doing
that on the internet in some ways I'm
being vulnerable right now just speaking
about some of the stuff and so in some
ways we can get into semantical traps
but I do like the word humility uh just
a little bit better yeah interesting I'm
not familiar with with using humility in
that way it's probably something that I
should look at a little bit more when I
think about humility I think about not
being too big-headed reducing the ego
um it seems like you're using a
different conception of it I think
humility is the very center of morality
and pride is the very center of
immorality
interesting why
well uh I I was one over to this way of
thinking and there's a book called Mere
Christianity by C.S Lewis ultimately it
will conflate through the moral uh it's
moral architecture it's ultimately
morality is something that's authored by
a moral law Giver if you don't have a
moral law Giver then you don't have a
real moral law other than something we
just make up that means whether it's the
individual that says this is what's
moral or whether society that makes some
type of social contract still Morality
In this case would be something that we
just make up because it's helpful but
it's not transcendently real and the
heat death of the universe in a million
years from now and we're all just gone
whatever moral musings will have now
will be just washed away and it'll be
meaningless in a Godless universe and so
ultimately morality would start by a
moral law giver and so if it's uh if God
is there then everything is about God
and not about us in which case Pride
would say things are about me and
humility would say no things aren't
about me I should live a selfless life
and humility then becomes this root that
grows out into every single other virtue
so that you can actually live selflessly
in every single uh respect uh and so
that's why I think people naturally
intrinsically know this and that's why
if you ever find somebody arrogant you
hate them but if you find some you know
your hero in some story is kind of like
a humble suffering that against
insuperable odds ends up winning the day
ever people root for that Underdog it's
because naturally pre-programmed in we
recognize humility is praiseworthy and
pride goes before a fall very good yes
so why is it important going back to the
warrior archetype why is it important
important to be the most dangerous man
in the room
sure so really if you check out that
chapter it looks like that chapter in my
book is going to be about hey the most
dangerous man in the room be the most
dangerous man in the room and really the
it unwinds this tale of when I thought I
was the most dangerous man in the room
and then I got my butt handed to me in a
way that I still haven't recovered from
Chris I'm still limping that one off can
you tell us the story of the 20 yeah
there was the girls soccer coach at my
high school came in one day into our
wrestling room he was going to be my
sparring partner I was a very good
wrestler I was the school's wrestler I
had all kinds of Records some of them
are probably still standing I was a good
wrestler at this school and so um it
didn't really matter if you were much
bigger than me I would beat our
heavyweight even though I was 130 uh and
so
um I say all that to say that when this
middle-aged kind of portly dude uh came
in I knew that he had some martial arts
background he's he was put with me which
I thought was really insulting of my
coach to do and we're kind of going
through some just different moves and
warm-ups and this guy I'm like man he's
got a little bit of a doe belly but this
dude moves slick and he was and he was
fast and we're just chatting while we're
going and then we start pushing into
more of like free wrestling and I mean
at this point I'm starting to get a
little frustrated and uh I'm going a
hundred percent and the dude just took
me apart uh and so he just while he was
chatting with me too so it's like he
didn't know I was in the fight of my
life and so uh anyway I realized uh
something about kind of pressing back
into Pride goes before a fall I noticed
that the most dangerous men on the
planet who I've worked with whether they
were uh Rangers or SEALS or Delta or you
know three letter agency contractors SAS
SBS I work with all kinds of really
really dangerous dudes and at the very
tippy top of those guys there are always
these more humble unassuming guys and
I'm like what is that what is that and
you realize the Arrogant guy can only
get so tough and it can only get so far
uh but you have to be teachable and to
be teachable well arrogance will only
let you get so far in that respect and
so I saw a lot of guys who were kind of
PT studs they get into ranger battalion
and then they'd wash out and then some
other guy with less impressive physique
but uh he's got a longer suffering grit
and character under the hood he had
deeper uh reservoirs and a soul to tap
into that dude didn't quit and he went
the distance and so that's really what
more of the chapters uh aiming at is we
find Incredible strength through
humility and I do press in it's not all
fluffy metaphorical stuff I go into some
real brass tacks of like hey let's be
tough guys in the uh more obvious and
traditional sense as well yeah I what do
you think it is about the guys that are
the most dangerous being more unassuming
which way do you think that Arrow of
causality
runs
do you think it's because they're so
dangerous that they choose to be
unassuming or is it in the other
direction
you know I
I am not sure but I I think humility uh
opens up humility is a seed that will uh
reap a harvest of uh I think blessing on
the other end and so a really arrogant
guy is very hard to teach anything to
and so that's part of it so that could
be really pragmatic that's his ability
to progress to continue to grow
I I think that that's that's definitely
it too and I think God's against them
yeah there's a one of the things that
Chris that a bodybuilder guy that I
spoke to said on the episode was
he doesn't have the
tyrannical
self-belief that someone like Michael
Jordan does so you know Michael Jordan
is he he wouldn't even dream of losing
if anybody slighted him there was this
sort of Rage fire that was lit
underneath him
um but Chris's approach is very
different he's like I think about losing
all the time it's like I'm scared of
losing I'm scared of losing to my
opponent but his idea was that by
because he has accepted the fact that he
may lose
he believes it's given him the potential
to be able to put it all on the line in
a way that someone who hadn't considered
the possibility of losing wouldn't be
able to do it yeah
um I would be more like uh more like him
in that and I really hate losing
logically I have to entertain the idea
and that and and through thinking
through wargaming how how I might lose
or or what would happen if that how I
can there's all kinds of useful nuggets
and then me that that can fuel my
preparation and I can find some fuel in
there for uh training and game planning
War planning it also keeps me from uh
not underestimating whatever I'm up
against I just know at an early age
especially on the wrestling man I hated
hated losing and so I want to run the
race uh to win so uh yeah but I'd also
say
um I don't want my identity wrapped up
in that I hate to lose just because I'm
competitive like that but uh I'll be
quick to say I am not one that is
chasing after the that golden carrot of
greatness I think great is significantly
overrated I would fall rather pursue
goodness hmm yeah you talk about men
being on a quest to achieve something
Beyond Fame and Fortune what is that I
think it's uh fool's gold man uh of that
life of man if I get this much money and
chicks are all about me and I got the
dream job and the dream car a lot of
folks if you really pay attention
there's plenty of people that have that
you can look in some of the most
miserable people you know are
extravagantly wealthy or in in dire
poverty you know and so now I recognize
also that people on their deathbed
aren't calling for their stock market
portfolios or looking at pictures of all
their vehicles or something at the end I
think it's Hollow I think what will
happen is the CEO that checked out of
his uh kids lives for decades hoping
that you just earn enough and be enough
realize that he missed the most
important things all along and all he
really cares about is is making things
right with the kids that he's estranged
from and he missed it he missed all the
good stuff and I would far far rather
downgrade my quantity of life so I can
scale up my quality of life and so I
would rather be a good man good man's
good men can make a Rippling wonderful
impacts on the world around them they
have uh terrific legacies where people's
lives were changed for the better that
they weren't just out pursuing some gold
medal or money in some you know some
huge uh bank account and and I'm not
against those things I'm like no I'm
going after that stuff too I'm like I'm
I'm gonna try to kill it at work and I'm
not gonna have a loser mentality either
I'm just recognizing as I go forward
toward all those good Pursuits I'm going
to keep the main thing the most
important thing my relationship with God
is more important than my bank account
you'd know that if you looked at my bank
account because you'd be like holy cow
son of a gun John gives him away a lot
and like yeah I do I think it's the most
I think that's more important uh you
would see that I spend a a lot of time
pouring into my kids and I'm making
memories with them all the time and me
and my wife were doing fantastic as I
said before then I've got deep
relationships that are growing around me
and I've got joy and I've got peace and
all that stuff builds a wonderful Legacy
and so that's what I'm after not writing
my name in the sky going back to what we
were talking about before that sort of
fear of failure your acceptance of it
even though you have a desire to win and
sort of Chris's almost embodiment of his
fear of failure I remember I played
Cricket that was the sport that I played
growing up very British and um
I remember I was so afraid of
disappointing my coaches or mum and dad
or whatever
um the way that Cricket gets played each
different type of player is quite
tactical and if the either game
conditions or the weather doesn't suit
it
um a lot of the time certain types of
players of which I was one can turn up
and not contribute to the game massively
so you just end up in field maybe you
didn't bat because you were batting down
the order and the weather wasn't
appropriate so that you didn't end up
bowling it's called a TFC a thanks for
coming and um
I remember each Monday I would have a
call with the coach from the county that
I was from and this is the equivalent of
you know whatever playing for your MLB
or a team um and I was on the youth
setup for Durham which is the
northernmost uh County setup in the UK
where I'm from
and I would have this call with my coach
and he would say how did you get on over
the weekend and there would almost be a
degree of relief in me when I got to say
oh man you know the pitch the the the
the conditions that weren't right uh I I
I you know I really wanted to bowl I
really wanted to get myself out there
but yeah the captain is just you know
he's not playing me he's not putting me
out there blah blah blah and there was a
degree of um of relief I remember I know
that there was a degree of relief in me
and I realized looking back that that
was me being scared it was me it was me
being cowardly because I would have
sooner
assured my inability to fail through not
being put onto the stadium floor rather
than face the potential defeat Now isn't
that interesting we waste so much time
and energy and stress so much because we
really just get the definitions of words
wrong and we give so much we give so
much ground in our lives to things like
fear I tell my sons all the time I'm
like boys it's okay to be afraid you're
just not allowed to let fear stop you
you know it's okay to cry we just cry
about the right things you know like hey
you stump your toe suck it up buttercup
men don't cry when they're physically
hurt we're going to be tough and that's
what I teach my boys uh but uh if you
cry because you're overcome with love
for somebody or you know something that
that's a your hardest move I'm like the
toughest dude I've ever heard of
absolutely is is the the one who split
time into Jesus Christ uh tortured that
doesn't cry out uh you know and just
absolutely uh moral strength spiritual
strength intellectual strength physical
so you had the the absolute the whole
package there
and what was that where was I going to
that I got distracted I talked about
talking about children and crying yeah
but geez that's right but Jesus wept I'm
like the strongest dude weeps I'm like
yeah yeah those are those are strong
tears those are strong tears of like
what you're overcome because you love
someone so much so that you're crying
like well that's not weakness that
that's strength of like no no a guy who
never cries that's really weak you must
love very little
how sad how weak and that's how I think
about it now
what about someone that resonates with
that story they maybe they may fear that
they do have an inner coward inside of
them in fact I've got another story that
I want to tell you
um that I wrote in a newsletter a little
a few weeks ago uh this is so good so
um I recently got to speak with someone
I've been curious about for a long time
he went through a difficult period many
years ago even though he's Beyond it now
he came very close to losing everything
financially reputationally
psychologically I asked him how he had
dealt with the darkest time he'd faced
he told me that he'd had a concern in
the back of his mind throughout his
entire life he was always worried that
deep down he might be a coward that
secretly he might not be the strong
capable person he thought he was that
when the rubber met the road he wouldn't
be able to stand up and face whatever
the world threw at him see many of the
challenges we face in life are largely
under our control we choose jobs we
apply for the house we try to afford the
partner we tried to seduce the weight we
even left these things can still be hard
tough challenging so sometimes
unbearably difficult but it was us who
chose the flavor of that difficulty so
what happens when absolutely everything
comes crashing down the single worst
possible scenario that you can imagine
happens well you get to see what you're
made of what you're genuinely made of
when all of your forces are marshaled to
a single Challenge and he said that he'd
had faith in himself but he'd never been
pushed hard enough to prove that his
faith was justified and this is a quote
from him he said I could always hear my
best self clearing his throat in the
room next door but when he never knew if
his self was able to come in when it was
needed it turns out that he did I love
the quote and I love the story because I
think many of us are uncertain about
just how capable we are maybe a couple
of times in your life all hell will
break loose and your best self will have
to stop his coughing and come to say
hello
well written Bravo it resonated
immediately with him it's like he's
there's the fear of the inner coward I'm
like what
yeah of course yes yes say it out loud
yeah you gotta you got a coward inside
you and so do I you know so do I and uh
there is
um okay I recognize where I'm at I
recognize I had the propensity to
cowardice in all kinds of areas of my
life and just because you're a hero in
one area doesn't mean that you're not
cowardly in another area I want to be
strong across the board you know if
you're a castle you want every single
door around the castle closed and if you
don't do that then you risk being
overwhelmed overcome and then you are
just on the ropes of life you can be
overthrown by life and so it's not good
to just have three really strong doors
and one weak one I'm like guess where
the chain breaks at the weakest Lincoln
so we want to be heroic in every single
respect and so I think there's great
stuff that you can do to grow
um amidst the fact that hey we could be
cowards I mean one is to just run at
whatever makes you afraid just make
yourself do it you're afraid of heights
well guess what you're going bungee
jumping OH Close spaces splunking
brother I'm like but I'm scared I'm like
yeah yeah but this is a great
opportunity to kill fear run at it
whatever you're afraid of that is where
you're gonna have to grow go turn around
and face it stop running and face it and
that's one way we can do it another way
and I think I find this very effective
as well as there's a place in the book
of First John uh and this is the Bible
it says perfect love casts out all fear
and it's absolutely true perfect love
casts out all fear of like you draw you
know your your kid goes overboard a
five-year-old kid in a shark infested
Water Mama Bear's gonna jump in you know
it's like you're afraid of stuff like
this man Mama bears are not afraid of
anything is that that perfect love of to
protect you know of oftentimes the
soldier is ready to
um fight and face death because they're
desperately uh trying to protect their
dudes their left and right it's about
the the soldier that that loving
camaraderie and so I I think if we're
perfected and love and character and
righteousness then you're not going to
be afraid the righteous is bold as lions
I want to I have a quick story because
there is a gal I talk about her husband
or um her late husband in the book um
the warrior poet way
um he'd become one of my first mentors
in ranger battalion he was he was under
the Jesus stuff before I was and so I
didn't really understand much of that
I'll I'll
um Kevin died
uh years after getting out of the
military
um in a motorcycle wreck and uh I was
very close to him he was the one that
officiated me and my wife's wedding so
very very close uh to him uh and that
was really hard and I remember getting
the call it was real real early in the
morning
um like two in the morning and I
remember his wife uh and she's just like
John
John and I knew something was wrong I'm
like oh Kelly shouldn't be calling me so
early
um in the morning and she told me what
would what was happening and she this
girl so strong she was trying to take
care of my upset the night that she
learned
um I I don't see Kelly very often but
she's on her way flying to spend the
weekend with us right now so
um anyway she'll be in this room here in
a couple hours I haven't seen her in a
very long time uh but um
I remember in the midst of that just
Brokenness and we are both weeping we
cannot keep this together at all uh
loved Kevin deeply deeply I said Kelly
what is God doing
and uh she said I don't know but he's
sovereign
basically what that means if I don't
know but he's in control it's going to
be okay that's what she said uh to me
that that's what that word sovereign
meant uh to her and I'm like holy smokes
talk about fear talk about Brokenness
uh this girl was strong and brave in
ways that I wasn't she's better than me
she's stronger than me and I love Kelly
for it uh but uh
anyway and I noticed that her faith was
what made her so strong
so there you go you talk in the book
about the importance of facing death
before you die why
so if you face death it will immediately
push all the vain Pursuits to the left
and right and all that you're left with
in the middle is what matters if you
face death if you realize uh what's
Worth Dying For You know what what's
worth living for
what does facing death look like
from a tactical perspective how what is
a way that people can practice doing
this oh gosh I mean I I'm understanding
how you use the word tactical now
because
strategically operationally how do we
get this to how can we get it to grow
corn
so I have some prescriptors some
recommendations in the books I don't
want to give everything uh away but I'll
say of man
yeah sure all right I I like you I like
your audience so good I'll go ahead and
give you this one I'll give you a juicy
one there you go but guys I'm now you
got to get it you got to go buy the book
because Link in the show notes below
brother there thanks brother uh so
before I ever went off to combat
uh one of the very first things I had to
do when I got to ranger battalion is
they packed me for war day one at range
of baton they packed me for War uh so uh
but uh then I immediately had to write a
death letter and your death letter is
your last words to family friends who
whatever put it in an envelope you seal
it and you hang it in your wall Locker
so that if you never come back your
buddies mail the letter and uh yeah
they're like okay boom all right you
write a death letter no big deal yeah
right uh especially you shipping off for
war you're like I may never come back
these May really be my last words uh and
I had
um I had some blurry letters and words
on that document where I wept over that
and so I I had to
um really do an audit of those
relationships and and I told people what
they meant to me and I tried to take any
business that may be unfinished and make
sure that it was finished so even after
that letter of like I gotta make some
calls I got to tell some people some
stuff I gotta offload some junk that
I've been dealing with I need to be
completely Unshackled unfettered Ready
To Die For A Cause And so
um it was really remarkable and so in in
the book I lead people to do just that
and go through that exercise you can't
be ready to die if you have unfinished
business if you have unresolved conflict
if you've withheld forgiveness for some
people that you should have if you owe
someone some apologies and you don't
realize it and furthermore you're not
ever ready to die if you haven't settled
the hardest questions of life is there a
God uh and if so if there's a God what
does that God want from us now am I
right with that God am I ready to am I
ready to die am I ready to kill am I
really really ready to kill over this if
like if somebody goes to carjack you're
ready to shoot him for it like the John
Wick one movie had a real problem with I
love John Wick movie by the way but he
he murders like 130 dudes because they
killed his dog he'd had for two weeks
and they stole his car which is probably
insured and they're like no no no you
don't get it it he loved the dog and it
was sentiment blah blah blah it's like
130 henchmen you killed some of those
guys are just you know working a Beat
Just like hey I got a new job today and
then he got whacked you had no idea
about the puppy killing situation thing
you just whacked a whole bunch of people
and now he gets to women Limitless rage
wow this is quite a uh
um quite a rabbit Trail but what is
worth dying for
what is worth killing for I don't care
about my wallet here taking my wallet
I'll have my credit cards canceled
within the hour I'm not it's not worth
killing you over I'd rather here here's
my car keys I'm buying your life so I
don't have to kill you for this and so
settling all those most important
philosophical and Theological questions
must be done because if you ever do
face your own demise and we never know
when that's going to come
let's say you have to act heroically you
got to push through and do something you
got to be brave you got to protect
somebody your brain can be ambushed by
those greater questions and unresolved
conflicts and things in your life that
are still in disarray and you'll find
yourself distracted by those items and
not able to keep your mind on the ball
in the present in in effect you can get
ambushed by all these questions and it
can rob your ability to
um
to do what needs to be done does all
that make sense it does I also imagine
that the unresolved conflicts or the
ungiven thanks and gratitude to the
people who need it that have shaped you
and helped you uh that just probably
ambiently sits you know somewhere just
in the back of your mind it just floats
around behind you and it'll surface just
a tiny little smidgen every week every
couple of weeks every month and it'll
just remind you and it's it's going to
be slowly just eroding away your
experience of life and on top of that as
well you know you have the opportunity
by reaching out to somebody who deserves
it with an olive branch or with
gratitude or with thanks or with
whatever it is by doing that
you get to live the the wonderful
opportunity of bathing in the reflective
glow of making somebody else feel good
while you're both still alive that's
good yeah I I love that if for me I can
be so stupid and kind of in my heart of
hearts that I may think something
doesn't bother me I'm like oh no no I'm
over that I'm over that and really I'm
not I don't feel I'm not thinking about
it but as you said it's kind of back
here it's someplace sitting brooding and
growing in my subconscious and my
conscious brain just didn't know
anything about it but I know that you
know dysfunction maybe you got a dad
that really did you wrong or something
else like that you're not going to
forgive him because he doesn't deserve
it just understand that that root uh
even if you're not thinking about it
consciously that root grows and it
becomes bitter and it infects and
poisons all Air all kinds of different
area uh uh parts of your life and so
being able to forgive people even
sometimes when they don't deserve it is
good even from a self-preservation
standpoint now forgiving someone isn't
the same as trusting them you know they
wronged you of like I forgive you I
release that but I'm not going to trust
you anymore trust is slowly earn and
quickly lost I'm not going to trust you
uh you know so anyway there's some
thoughts
John let's bring this one home mate I
really appreciate you uh I love the fact
that you're trying to marry these two
worlds
um I I really think that we could
probably do with more Warriors and more
poets and less of the passivity that
we're seeing at the moment if people
want to check out the book and all of
the other stuff that you do and your
courses why should they go the warrior
poet way is the best place to find the
book The Warrior poetway.com uh that's
going to land you on our website too so
you can kind of hunt around but our
website is Warrior poetsociety.com from
there you can find our YouTube stuff and
our social media good luck they're gonna
censor that like crazy sense so even if
you click on the stuff who knows whether
they'll serve it up to you they hate us
because we tell the truth and so uh yeah
party on man John I appreciate you thank
you mate use well thanks brother if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe